small crowds in eastern ukraine's
breakaway regions celebrated russian
president vladimir putin's decision to
recognize their independence on monday
[Applause]
to recognize these
territories which are on ukraine's side
of the border as russian territories
that gives him a pretext to send in
troops
because the pro-russian authorities in
these two areas
uh say that they feel like they're under
threat from the kiev government and can
russia please protect them
western authorities say russia has
massed as many as 190 000 troops around
ukraine
now putin has ordered what he calls
peacekeeping forces to enter the
breakaway regions in response to what
the kremlin says is aggression by
ukrainian forces
tanks were photographed in the city of
donyask and witnesses said russian
military vehicles poured in early
tuesday local authorities didn't
immediately confirm the arrival of
russian troops
this is a major escalation
because he's sending russian troops onto
the territory of a sovereign country
that is ukraine it threatens to end the
negotiations that have been going on
for
weeks now
in europe
aimed at trying to get him to
de-escalate the situation at the border
russia said it's still open to diplomacy
but putin's move further complicated
those efforts to find a solution and
triggered a wave of condemnation among
world leaders this is plainly in breach
of international law russia should step
back
ukrainian president vladimir zelinski
discussed the crisis with president
biden and addressed the nation
after putin's announcement president
biden signed an executive order that
will prohibit u.s investments and trade
in the breakaway regions
so this is not the big
um
salvo of sanctions that the u.s and
europe have been promising those could
still come it's limited probably because
they want to hold that stuff in their
quiver if president putin decides to
invade the rest of the country
the u.s and its allies have threatened
to unleash potentially crippling
sanctions against russia targeting its
major banks state companies and key
imports if it invades ukraine i think
that we can expect to see more
efforts at hail mary diplomacy but on
the other hand we could see president
putin
escalating further and sending troops
into the rest of ukraine and taking kiev
or we could also see
uh the kind of cyber attacks that uh the
u.s intelligence and the u.s government
has been expecting